May 2014 an undeclared war rages in the
Ukraine the conflict attracts the
attention of military and civilian
satellite image analysts all over the
world one unusual picture arouses fears
of a deadly threat in the country's vast
dark forests it looks like some kind of
badly drawn Neolithic chalk carpet what
I see is a large area that is whited out
but you're not sure as to exactly what
it is the image comes from an area of
central Ukraine near the border with
Belarus
the white shape looks artificial but
it's in a patch of isolated forest the
closest buildings belong to a ghost town
devoid of human life
this is one of the most contaminated
places on earth in 1986 this area was
close to the site of a devastating
nuclear accident when the Chernobyl
atomic power plant exploded the most
feared condition in the field of nuclear
energy has finally happened there was an
explosion followed by this nuclear fire
burning for ten days many Chernobyl
cleanup personnel known locally as the
liquidators died from radiation
poisoning nearby towns were evacuated to
escape the radioactive gases spreading
across Europe in poisoned wind the
radiation poisoning after an atomic
blast or nuclear bomb is very similar to
radiation poisoning from a nuclear
meltdown like a Chernobyl nuclear
investigator Tim Mousseau
considers the theory that the white
patch in the forest could be the result
of radioactive fallout the fallout was
really patchy and so you actually see
this quilt work of a brand new activity
throughout the area
trees near Chernobyl actually turned red
and then died off maybe that's what's
happened here there were so many dead
trees and many of them were so
radioactive that they ended up taking
some of these trees and burying them
under the ground but there's a problem
with the theory the color of the ground
radiation poisoning doesn't explain to
me why the area's turned white it would
be very unlikely that you would see a
patch that looked like this particular
image this is the precision and order
the lines are perfectly straight
expanses of brilliant white ground seen
from space can be telltale signs of
large-scale mining operations one of the
most commonly mined white materials is
phosphate white phosphate mines do
create this white reflective metallic
shear and in fact there have been white
phosphate mines in Ukraine phosphorus is
a key ingredient in advanced fire weapon
the Ukrainian military has been accused
of using it against Russian separatists
in 2014 but examination of the wider
area beyond the white mark suggests that
mining is not the answer when you look
more closely at the image you realize
that there's actually no mining
infrastructure if it was a mine you'd
see mining trucks and other mining
machinery but we're not seeing that here
so what else could it be close
examination of the white areas of the
image shows signs the photo has been
tampered with there's a blotchy sort of
white pattern as if someone has taken
white paint and dabbed it you really
cannot see in any detail no matter how
far you zoom in or out what it possibly
is
why would someone tamper with this image
what are they hiding
high-definition satellite images are now
so widely available they can pose a
threat to national security the security
services of many countries respond to
the threat with a process known as
redaction images of sensitive locations
are modified before they're uploaded to
online mapping sites the white blotches
might be evidence that the Ukrainian
government has something to hide all
governments regularly do this they will
take the original satellite data and
they will alter it it keeps enemies from
being able to specify points of interest
intelligence sources suggest that many
redacted satellite images conceal
military installations this looks just
like a lot of the redaction that's done
over any military facility the situation
on the ground in Ukraine is highly
volatile Russian backed separatists have
NX Crimea keeping military installations
from enemy view makes strategic sense
clandestine military bases are often
seen tucked away in remote parts of
forests analysts scour the rest of the
image for possible signs of military
activity but find none
there don't seem to be enough roads or
rail lines or even an airfield for it to
be a substantial military base research
into historical image archives produces
an unredacted photo of the same area the
older photograph reveals what is hiding
beneath the white blotches
it's a massive parking lot but why is it
there you see choppers and trucks parked
in the clearing what could be so special
about them that somebody wanted scrubbed
from the image
the deserted roadways of Chernobyl and
the nearby town of Pripyat offer a clue
it's like a post-apocalyptic scene from
a videogame the buildings are in place
the school is in place the amusement
park is in place but there's no cars no
trucks no buses
they've all been removed the Soviet
government knew that they had thousands
and thousands of irradiated vehicles and
the last thing that they wanted was
people taking these contaminated cars
and trucks and driving them all over the
Soviet Union or simply parked in the
middle of forests and big fence put
around it and keep out signs put up the
white blotches mask the deadliest
parking lot on the planet where over a
thousand irradiated vehicles have been
left to rot the medals themselves can't
be washed off these will be very
dangerous for thousands of years to come
the lethal threat posed by the
radioactive vehicles is supposed to be
contained but security is lacs and
potentially deadly radioactivity is
spreading beyond the containment area
people's garbage these vehicles for
metal or parts or whatever to be able to
sell them on the black market or to
recyclers people were coming in and
stripping off car parts and selling them
off that would be disastrous to the
Ukrainian economy visa disastrous to
their environment
it's likely the Ukrainian government
redacted the image to conceal the
location of a contaminated metal from
other would-be scavengers